So I shall start.
Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambhogamsa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambhogamsa
Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhasa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
Excuse me, I'm out of voice.
I've not been talking for a while.
It's all gone husky.
okay so tonight uh we're gonna have a look at this forgiveness most of you i'm sure have done exercises on this so i'll just go through the basics and then we'll we'll practice it so i think there are two fundamental attitudes which really inform all our virtues and the first one is gratitude
now once we once we realize we cannot pay back what we've actually received you know our life from our mother and father etc etc then of course it moves you you want to give something back so it moves to all those qualities of love compassion generosity etc and uh forgiveness is the other one that that's dealing with all the dark side all the um the guilt the shame
the unforgivingness, all that sort of stuff.
So with these two fundamental or basic attitudes, I think we can have a happy life.
So, the first thing to reckon, the first time to remind ourselves is that all the emotions we suffer around forgiving, trying to forgive somebody, being forgiven,
asking for forgiveness and forgiving ourselves, all the emotional stuff, remember, is all self-made.
So, you know, when somebody says something that is a bit nasty, our response is our response.
They didn't cause that.
So that's the first thing to remind ourselves.
All the stuff we're going to work with has been made by me.
and the idea of course is to undermine them and then they will transform naturally that's the other thing we have to remember all negative states will eventually transform themselves to the opposite nothing is lost where there's hatred there'll be love and so on and the final note on this is it's for us so forgiveness is for us it's not for them
uh which might sound a bit selfish but they've also got the same problem with us right so whatever we're doing here now asking for forgiveness forgive forgiving etc they also have their own problems and when they're doing forgiveness practice they're doing it just for themselves
So it's basically a practice for our own benefit if the other person, to say, is affected by it, all well and good.
So for instance, if we apologize to somebody and they feel the heart to respond, that's good.
We've been a catalyst for their movement, their heart movement.
But of course, they don't have to forgive us.
That's sometimes difficult to accept.
uh the next thing is about attitudes so these are sankaras most of you know that word sankara it's normally translated as volitional conditions which doesn't mean very much but it's basically the choices we make the habits we have which are conditioned and conditioning that's the important thing so these are energetic
conditionings yeah and where i the way i think of them is like it's like they're balloons of particular types of reactivity so uh i might for instance be very annoyed when people are late okay so every time somebody's late i get irritated right and i don't look at it i don't think about it so this balloon of irritation around people being late grows and grows and grows and then one day somebody's too late
and it's like a pin touches this balloon and all this irritation and anger just burst out and that's where you get this rage this road rage and all the stuff we hear about so what we're doing is we're letting the steam we're letting the the bad air out of that balloon okay so there are three subjects obviously uh we have to be we have to make uh
The ability to ask for forgiveness easy for ourselves.
It's against our pride, you know, but we have to make it easy.
And then we have to ask for forgiveness.
That's also something we don't like doing.
And then finally we've got to forgive ourselves, which is often the most difficult.
Now, the process is we remember something,
And we have an event.
And that event carries with it all the loadings that we put on it.
The hurt, the anger, etc.
So the event comes to mind.
Now we have to be careful, really careful, it doesn't shoot off into a fantasy.
once we're up there in the clouds fantasizing whether we like it or not we're making things worse right whatever the and that emotion is is being exercised and made worse by storytelling so as soon as we see that happening we just come back and we try to hold that frame fairly still and while we're doing that the attention of course is drawn to what's coming from the heart
So what might come up is hurt, say somebody said something, so hurt.
And the next protocol is how we're relating to this hurt.
Now we don't like to accept that because it's against our pride.
So we have to allow that aversion, that not wanting to disappear, until we can allow the heart to express its hurt completely.
That's the healing process.
So we're using this little image that we've got, this event, to get in touch with the hurt.
And that hurt, of course, is connected to all the hurts that we have, just like the anger in that balloon is connected to all the other angers.
And as we let out one little bit of anger, everything else is affected.
So it's systemic.
Everything we do has a systemic effect on our own hearts and minds.
Now, when we're doing this, by the way, if as you come, say, to forgive somebody, you can't do it.
Fine.
You don't worry about that at all.
You just keep working on the hurt.
And then eventually the heart softens and you can do it.
OK. And we always start with a bit of meta just to warm the heart up a bit.
And then we we ask for forgiveness.
We forgive others and then we forgive ourselves.
now when we're asking for forgiveness the first thing that might come up is the reason why the person did it okay and so you've got to be aware of that relationship you have to the person but basically you're looking at the hurt and when that passes perhaps the desire of revenge and you have to let that go too
yeah I'm just scrolling through here you seem to have lost something yes okay when it comes to forgiving when it comes to forgiving that's the next bit we're doing
Again, there's that hardness that's in the heart.
It doesn't want to forgive.
And there's a story here.
You know, when the Islamist blew himself up in London, this is going back a bit, there was an Anglican priest that left the order saying she couldn't carry out the ministry because she couldn't forgive the bomber who'd killed her daughter.
But it's actually never a case of can't, it's a case of won't.
um and let's just hope that distraught mother had you know has found a way eventually to open up her heart and of course if we look around the world at this moment must be a lot of mothers who were utterly distraught at what happened to their children young and old yeah but then you get a story like uh the mother who went to see her son's murderer and finally took him home when he was let out of prison and treated him like a son
so we have to remember that to forgive somebody is not to try and forget something that that's of course as we know is suppressive uh we're just trying to release the emotional charge sometimes when we do that we feel we're condoning what they do but that's that's not so that's just wrong feeling we're sort of letting them off
uh but obviously where amends and compensation is needed uh definitely we should ask for it and especially uh where there's justice you know where we need justice for uh grievous bodily harm rape all that all that dreadful stuff which i hope none of you suffered from uh but then of course you you have to seek justice but not with that anger not with that desire for vengeance
And of course, sometimes you have to stay away from people who harmed us.
You know, you have to protect yourself.
That's not a problem.
And then finally, forgiving ourselves.
So forgiving ourselves.
There are two contemplations that are really helpful.
First one is dependence origination.
So remember, in dependent origination, we start off with abhija, this ignorance, which produces a delusive idea about the world.
And it's really based along the idea of a self.
And we're trying to seek happiness in the world.
And we do it in this way that creates suffering.
And as we practice, we can see the cause, the psychological cause of that, which is the desire, the wrong desire.
and the fact that we're holding on to things which are impermanent it doesn't make sense and eventually to undermine that whole concept of a self we have it's a feeling concept it's not just a heavy a head concept and what this does is of course it takes us towards wisdom so one movement is from ignorance delusion and then the process of insight which takes us to wisdom
From the heart's point of view, just as the delusion, we cannot be blamed for the delusion,
The ignorance isn't culpable.
So from the heart's point of view, we're never meant to do any harm.
The heart has always been pure in its intentions.
But because of this delusion, it leads itself to being acquisitive, to being aversive, to being fearful, and so on.
So all these, of course, have produced unwholesome actions.
And then there's the consequence of that, which we're dealing with now.
or forgiving this business and when all that's purified uh we end up with the pure heart right so that that's the process from from a sort of pure heart through all this negativity we work with it and it's basically most is it's the sweat when it comes to the spiritual practice the other bits easy the insight's not a problem is it it's just it's just you know all the guns in the heart that we're trying to get rid of
and that leads us to purity purity immaculacy back to purity and immaculacy so the buddha talks about it like um you know dirt that gets on a cloth and when you wash it the cloth goes back to its original loveliness so that's what that's the that's the projection that we're on that's the pro that's what that's what we're doing
And the other one is about karma.
So that's pretty, I mean, at its simplest equation, you do something which is harmful, some harm will come of it.
You never know what, right?
And remember that the harm, if it's outwardly, for what we speak and what we do, you don't know what the effect will be.
It goes into a matrix of relationships.
and the same happens to us when we do something every time we say something or do anything whether it's good or bad it affects the whole it's a systemic effect inside us right affects the whole psychology in some way or uh so now the uh the bit that i found really relieving was that when we do something wrong there is a karmic
response to it there'll be a react there'll be something comes back to it and that's all we have to suffer all the business about punishment and the way we talk to ourselves and the the recrimination the self-recrimination the anguish and all that all that's not necessary all that's necessary is to receive the consequence of unwholesome action just to receive it with patience and bear with it until it also will dry up pass away
So that's an interesting reflection, I think, on karma.
So don't feed the critic.
That's the big thing.
Okay.
So we'll do the practice.
We'll do the practice together.
And then I'm going to put what is actually a written piece here as a PDF on the website with this video.
So that if you want you can download it and just look at it and use it.
Okay, so we can begin our practice by just sitting quietly.